[Applauso]
Ciao
io mi chiamo Lisa vareschi e sono tre
cose nella vita
Sono una filosofa sono femminista e sono
vegana
In pratica la presentazione più
spaventosa del mondo Me ne rendo conto
Cioè di base una [ __ ]
se anche voi siete almeno una di queste
cose nella vita o una voce fuori dal
coro lo sapete
ci mettiamo in discussione guardiamo il
mondo da prospettive sempre diverse
siamo in continua evoluzione
siamo delle persone [ __ ]
filosofia femminismo e veganismo non
sono tre scelte casuali
o meglio All'inizio pensavo lo fossero
fino a quando non ho incontrato il
titolo di un volume molto interessante
Nature is a family
la natura è un problema femminista
Ora non so se capita anche a voi ma in
genere quando io dico di essere
femminista
le risposte che ottengo sono tre
La prima è a loro gli uomini
La seconda è Ah quindi non posso più
dire niente
e la terza è no no no no io non sono
femminista Invece io sono per la parità
il femminismo sicuramente ha
attraversato nel corso dei secoli ondate
modi di comunicare
obiettivi strategie differenti tra loro
Ma cosa significa femminismo oggi
significa uguaglianza
no
femminismo significa parità
e parità è uguaglianza sono due termini
che vediamo sempre più spesso utilizzati
come interscambiabili
Ma se ne osserviamo più da vicino
vediamo che non è così
si può richiedere l'uguaglianza tra
tutte le persone
No perché non siamo tutti e tutte uguali
si può richiedere però la parità tra
tutte le persone
perché ogni persona ha il diritto di
avere dei diritti i diritti fondamentali
Questo è il femminismo oggi
Ma questo non è un Ted sul femminismo in
senso lato non sono qua per attaccare il
bottone sul femminismo in generale Qui
stiamo parlando di eco
elenco del femminismo arriva dappertutto
anche dove non c'è lo Aspetteremo
ad esempio nella natura
e all'interno di questo mondo Io ho
scoperto l'eco femminile
Ecco il femminismo nasce Nel 1974 dalla
francese François
e ci indica un movimento che mira a
unire le battaglie per la salvaguardia
della natura alle battaglie per il
riconoscimento dei diritti delle donne
è molto interessante nascono testi su
testi le autrici iniziano a scrivere di
questo macro argomento che è la natura
si parla di ambiente si parla di etica
della cura si parla di Popoli nativi
si parla di economia di politica chi più
ne ha più ne metta la natura è un tema
molto vasto
fino a quando a un certo punto si crea
una spaccatura all'interno del movimento
da una parte
l'eco femminile radicali
radicali sono quelli che rifiutano la
sovrapposizione dell'immagine della
donna a quella della natura Mi spiego
meglio
abbiamo presente la raffigurazione
classica di Madre Natura no
è questa qua
è la donna nuda vestita solo di edera
meravigliosa non la vogliamo più
è sessista
oggettifica noi e oggettifica la natura
noi Eco femminista radicali prendiamo le
distanze da questa immagine e possiamo
portare avanti le nostre battaglie
femministe le nostre battaglie per la
natura senza questa immagine
dall'altra parte
l'eco femminile culturale
che invece abbracciano questo dualismo e
dicono noi siamo donne
siamo madri
Ma questa frase non andrà a finire dove
avete immaginato
e facciamo parte della natura
la maternità È una cosa naturale così
come lo è la spiritualità
rivendichiamo questo dualismo
rivendichiamo queste figure
ora il discorso problematico per l'Eco
femminismo culturale e che quando si
portano avanti delle battaglie così
importanti e si chiama in causa la
questione biologica e la questione
religiosa
il rischio di cadere nel tranello degli
stereotipi di genere è dietro l'angolo
Ma nonostante le spaccature interne
l'ecofeminismo è andato avanti
ed è arrivato fino a noi
quando mi sono presentata all'inizio mi
sono presentata come filosofa femminista
e vegana
per un determinato periodo della mia
vita ho frequentato l'attivismo vegano
quello che viene chiamato l'attivismo
animalista
e sono scesa in piazza ho urlato le mie
ragioni con i cartelli ho manifestato
contro quello che pensavo fosse ingiusto
contro quello che anche adesso penso sia
ingiusto
fino a quando non ho sentito frasi che
hanno iniziato a non piacermi più
la donna che indossava una pelliccia era
una [ __ ]
la donna che sperimentava sui topi in
laboratorio
era una [ __ ]
e la donna che entrava al circo
Ovviamente era una [ __ ]
e questa cosa non mi piaceva più perché
chiamare le donne [ __ ] in un senso
volutamente dispregiativo significava
saltare a cavalcioni sulla schiena del
patriarcato e rendere una battaglia
giusta una battaglia marcia
e quando ho chiesto di poter parlare con
queste persone
la risposta che mi è stata data
Eccola è arrivata la femminista
quasi come se
esprimere il mio punto di vista
togliesse importanza la battaglia che
stavo portando avanti lì in quel momento
in quel luogo
Ecco il femminismo significa questo
significa riconoscere il fatto che due
battaglie possono essere portate avanti
contemporaneamente e in modo equo
Ma capisco la preoccupazione di queste
persone
perché l'eco femminismo come tutti i
femminismi
ha una caratteristica sociale molto
importante
fa paura
fa paura perché la prima cosa che ci
immaginiamo quando parliamo di
ecofeminismo sono queste donne con la
coroncina di fiori no che abbracciano
gli alberi
mentre odiano gli uomini per il discorso
fatto prima
fa paura perché mi permettete una
piccola digressione filosofica
parlare di natura
per chi parla di filosofia è molto
complicato ci sono dei filosofi dei
filosofi in sala C'è qualcuno sì sì sì
sì sì ok lo sapete benissimo
natura è un pendio scivoloso perché la
natura è un argomentazione che è usata
spesso
da chi parla di diritti o meglio Da
parte di chi vuole negare dei diritti
perché all'improvviso la natura quella
donna nuda vestita solo di edera
è fatta così
è sacra e immutata immutabile non si può
andare contro natura
fa paura anche perché il dualismo
donna natura
e uomo cultura e antichissimo è radicato
nella nostra società
la donna è irrazionale è istintiva è
selvatica ma è docile
l'uomo è la cultura è l'intelligenza e
la forza il controllo
e in controllo di sé
E proprio per questo deve essere in
controllo degli altri della donna e
della natura
E cosa ha fatto l'idea di uomo in questi
secoli
ha represso ha schiacciato attentato di
controllare e ha soffocato la donna
ha represso ha schiacciato tentato di
controllare e ha soffocato la natura
donne animali non umani e ambiente sono
spesso stati considerati e spesso lo
sono ancora
oggetti
proprietà di qualcun altro
Ecco il femminismo significa riconoscere
le dinamiche di dominio che da secoli
pervadono la nostra società
e distruggere smantellare lottare per
liberare e ricostruire
Ecco perché essere scomode sempre
Grazie
[Applauso]